dollie it's an absolute pleasure to meet
you well thank you how are you feeling
of about 95 musical hitting the London
stage well I'm feeling excited more than
anything I cannot wait to see all the
new cast if they're doing all the songs
that I've written for the plays like
here my my songs will call up my kids so
I said like seeing my kids in recital
but with this wonderful cast so I'm
hoping that we all have a good time
the cast seem to be having a good time
and they're loving it and I'm just dying
to see it all coming together and it's
almost 40 years since the film came out
I mean no are you surprised but it still
resonates with so many people it's just
like it won't die it's the gift that
keeps on giving because number five as
you know we did that in 79 it came out
in 80 and that was part of my deal was
that I would write the theme song you
hope for the best you hope you get a
good sign
[Music]
when you did write that song back in the
70s 40 years on our women where you
thought they would be 40 years on what
do you think there's still a long way to
go well I think there's gonna always be
a long way to go it's just a work in
progress as life itself is respect women
in the workplace so I really think
that's why we're here now with this new
with it with the new me to movement it
kind of brought up the subject again
with the harassment in the workplace and
the fact that women are still not
getting a chance to do as much just as
they can or paid you know equal for the
work that they do and so there's still
all those issues I really think that
when that came out in the ages it really
did do a lot of good it really did shine
the light on that you mentioned me - I
mean you managed to navigate a career
really successfully you made a lot of
really savvy business decisions at a
time when it can't have been that easy
being a woman in that industry did you
have issues coming through the industry
well you know I didn't really think
about it like that at the time because I
had grown up with with me and I have six
brothers and my dad my uncles I was
always close to you know all the men and
my family I've known a lot of great men
so I never was you know I didn't think
about it that much of course I've been
hit on all my life you know any young
girl would be but a lot of that I just
took as a compliment but I never you
know I never did anything to try to get
ahead in the business you know I never
slept with anybody listened wanted to
and I'd never put myself in a position
where I tried to stay out of those
positions and if I found myself in that
I was lucky that I had a great
personality and a great sense of humor
that I could joke my way out of a lot of
it and then if I couldn't I have enough
temper and backbone that I would kind of
get out of it some other way but I did
work it was a man's world back then and
I enjoyed it when we saw you up in the
stage just last weekend at the Grammys
with all of this fantastic young talent
around you're seeing up there with you
do you think the life for those young
women starting off in the industry
already enormously successful those
women you were singing with is it better
for them no do you think I think it is
and I think we've made a lot of good
good progress and a lot of good points
and I do think though that I think the
people are more open than I'm hoping
that you know that we can get out there
and do what we think we couldn't do I
mean we can be a little more aggressive
and now that we've better you know no
more of an open path now and I think we
can just go for it and just keep doing
what we do and I think that's what we
always have to do I'm proud to be a
woman and I'm you know it's like I look
like a woman but I think like a man
because I do know how men think because
I just you know meaning that I you know
I don't think of it in terms of male or
female I just think of it in terms of
getting a job done
in terms of your image you've always had
a very feminine image very sexy but also
very joyous very glam very fun and you
talk about your girls but we've never
seen your girls our house when you wanna
see em out fully when you look at the
young girls today and I know obviously
Miley Cyrus's your goddaughter but when
you see people like Miley in their pants
and videos do you think oh go put it
away or do you think go girl you wear
what you want - well I don't try to tell
other people what to do people are
always saying what kind of advice would
you give us I don't give people advice I
have information if you want to know
some facts and if you want to know you
know sometimes how I dealt with
something but I do believe that
everybody has a right to be themselves
everybody has their own path and their
own Road to walk and everybody's talent
is different and I think that we have to
kind of base you know just how we look
how crazy you know the people look all
the you know the images that you know
the people have it's what they feel
right about in themselves and I think
they have a right to do that so I it's
not up to me to tell them not to do it
cuz Who am I to tell anybody what to do
I mean I look like you know the town
and that's how patterned my look
after the town so Who am I to tell
somebody else how to dress or what to do
but your your image is very much part of
who you are but also you've chosen
projects and you've written songs that
are feminist you support a Transamerica
you that the film about trans rights in
America and dumplin great film that's
just been out recently you've always
been really ahead of the curve in terms
of society
have you intentionally sought out
projects like that I've got your heart I
think they just come to me and I'm
always there in place and I think that I
just live my femininity I mean I'm not a
people say are you a feminist I don't
know I don't know exactly what that
means I'm proud to be a woman I'm proud
to be a woman in business I'm proud to
to do what I do but I like to just live
it I like to be an example and you're
right I wrote some of the my first
single on RCA Records back in the
sixties it was called just because I'm a
woman
and it was it addressed the issues that
we're addressing now and then I all
through the years I've written you know
these songs that were strengthening to
empower women but just people you know
in general and it's the empowerment
doesn't actually because that theme that
runs through so much of your work it's
joyous there's dignity and it's
empowerment and it's about saying how
brilliant women are but not saying how
rubbish men are it's and one of them in
the new 95 musical my first line in the
in the new song that kind of took the
place at the fantasy scene it says I
love me and don't get me wrong I've
always had one of my own many good men
I've known but then there's you mean a
mr. Hart so I've known a few of them but
I've known more good men in my life than
I have bad ones and of course we all
come across those people but there's a
lot of bad women in this world who I've
worked with us I've worked with a lot of
women that were and you know as
as any boss could be so it's just
about the person you know it's just how
we treat each other with respect do you
think in your lifetime you'll see a
female president in America I think
there could be very well could be but
she needs to be smart she needs to know
what she's doing she don't need to be
just trying to take it just to prove a
point because she's a woman she needs to
have the goods she needs to have the
knowledge she needs to have the backbone
to be able to run a country I don't
think we're gonna ever have a woman
president if we don't really feel like
she's capable of saving the country or
saving the world for that matter when
you look back over your life you know 26
number one's the most decorated country
music star you know you're an absolute
icon but also your literacy project
and the money that you've pumped back
into Pigeon Forge with doli doli world
what do you think you'd be most proud of
well I'm proud of all of it I have to
answer save because you never know when
you start out how you're going to be
known or thought of when you're older
you hope for the best but I'm really
proud of the imagination library that
the project that I've done when we give
books to children but I've been very
proud of everything that I've
accomplished to be in the Songwriters
Hall of Fame because my songwriting is
very important but I won't mind being
known as the book lady but I want to be
known for my music as well and to have
left something great in the world that
wasn't there before I came along and do
you think that's what your mum and dad
would be most proud of as well I think
my mom and dad would be very proud of me
I always think they're looking down and
saying you go girl we knew you could do
it and we love you totally thank you so
much for talking to us it's been an
absolute pleasure thank you